[Music]
few days ago we were all just hitting
that watching the Super Bowl and bad
robot dropped a new Cloverfield movie
faster than Tom Brady managed to drop
that Lombardi Trophy but before I can
get into the things you missed in this
new Cloverfield movie let's do a quick
recap of everything in the Cloverfield
films and Arg so far because I will be
referencing back to them if you aren't
familiar with AR geez it stands for
alternate reality game in other words
it's a viral marketing technique that
was used to create buzz for each of
these movies primarily through the
creation of websites and Twitter
accounts that live within the
Cloverfield universes they typically
drop cryptic clues and leave fans to
decipher their meaning to unlock the
next piece of the puzzle and one other
thing the clover Arg s
are considered canon so most of the Arg
for the first Cloverfield movie takes
place on the tiger Otto website if you
aren't familiar Tiger Otto is a Japanese
mining company considered to be the most
advanced in the world and known for
their deep-sea oil drilling stations
that can drill miles and miles further
underwater than their competitors some
people believe it is one of these
drilling stations in the Atlantic that
awaken the dormant Cloverfield monster
or possibly monsters in 2008 but aside
from deep-sea drilling they also own
several subsidiary companies like
Yoshida Medical Research a deep-sea
bioprospecting company what the heck
does that mean basically they study deep
sea creatures in extreme environments to
see how they survive and how that can be
applied for human survival Tiger Ottawa
also owns a technology firm called bold
future which develops technology for
military and space exploration that
includes developing satellites so
obviously we'll be coming back to that
one
then there's paraffin wax distributors
though it's unclear how that one ties in
with the other subsidiaries the last one
is a beverage company called slusho the
company that Rob from the first
Cloverfield was planning to move to
Japan to manage slusho famously uses a
secret ingredient called deep-sea nectar
known to make the consumer feel happy
and have numerous health benefits some
people believe that this nectar is
extracted from the egg of the
Cloverfield monster and that the
drilling station in the Atlantic near
New York City is actually collecting the
snack
this is because the parasites that come
off the monster are found to have high
levels of nectar in their blood and that
leads us into the first Arg which is
about a group of extreme environmental
activists known as tidal wave who go to
this Atlantic Station to try to expose
Tagg grotto for some kind of dark secret
that they're supposedly hiding there the
station is destroyed in late 2007 and
tagged rot so blames this extremist
group for attacking it however I'll show
you the video and let you be the judge
of what happened the incident is being
coined an environmental disaster and a
matter of life and death for almost 300
individuals aboard the large deep-sea
drilling platform it went down days ago
and only now are we beginning to learn
details regarding the oil rig collapse
and what may have caused such a
devastating accident this dramatic home
video captured by eyewitnesses on the
scene shows a large oil rig
we had an ocean suddenly sinking under
violent and unexplained circumstances
the destruction of the qu i drilling
station happening dangerously close to
the coast of Connecticut sending
hundreds of workers scrambling for help
is a large oil rig collapsed video
footage shot earlier shows signs Boyle
is possibly seeping from the big rig
into the sea the dark shape below the
surface appears to be an oil spill that
could easily mean a nightmare for the
shoreline of Connecticut yeah
oil spill shortly after this happens the
final extraordinary clip clearly shows
the sheer speed and power of the sinking
vessel it appears that the oil rate is
being sucked down at a dramatic rate but
what caused the shower of debris that
followed remains a matter for intense
speculation
[Music]
shortly after in May 2008 New York
City's attacked on the evening of Rob's
going-away party his brother Jason is
killed by what appears to be a tentacle
monster destroying Brooklyn Bridge Rob
finds out that Beth the girl that he's
in love with is trapped in her apartment
he sets out to rescue her and is joined
by his late brother's girlfriend Lily
and his friend hood who serves as the
cameraman and Marlena a girl from the
party Marlena gets bit by a parasite and
dies they save Beth and Lily gets away
on shopper number 402 Rob Beth and HUD
aren't so lucky and that's where the
first movie ends I can't say for sure
quite yet but there's a good chance that
everything in 10 Cloverfield Lane and
its Arg take place in another dimension
where the New York City attack hasn't
happened yet and I promised this all
ties back into the Cloverfield paradox
so hang with me in 2009 a military
analyst named Howard Stambler joins bold
future the satellite company I told you
about and seven years later he's honored
on Tiger Otto's web site as employee of
the month according to the web site
Howard's drive commitment and refusal to
accept easy answers resulted in a
significant breakthrough diagnosing
transmission complications with two of
their government satellites at some
point Howard's ex-wife takes custody of
their daughter Megan and he goes a bit
crazy creating a website designed to
appeal to her and send her secret
messages meanwhile he's building a
doomsday bunker he later kidnaps young
girls and makes them where Megan's old
clothes to fill the gap left by his
daughter in 2016 he uses the secret
website to urge his daughter to run away
from her mother and come take cover in
his doomsday shelter suggesting that
something huge is about to happen his
daughter never shows up and Howard gets
desperate and finds someone to fill the
role of his daughter during the attack
and that person is Michelle the
protagonist of 10 Cloverfield Lane
Howard finds her at the Kelvin gas
station follows her knocks her off the
road and she wakes up in the bunker it's
just her Howard and a man named Emmett
who helped Howard build the bunker when
I mean Michelle find out that Howard was
lying about his daughter
they devised plans for Michelle to
escape Howard finds out about the
lands and kills Emmett but Michele gets
out to find that the air is clean but
worm like aliens have taken over the
earth she escapes towards a possible
survivors camp which is the end of 10
Cloverfield Lane but the Arg extends a
little bit past that a box left by
Howard is found containing data about a
particle detector from the International
Space Station that picked up two huge
bursts followed by a massive red flash
that occurred everywhere presumably the
same event described by Emmett at the
beginning of the Cataclysm the next
event happens in January 2018 not long
before the release of the Cloverfield
paradox so I'm gonna go ahead and fire
up that things you miss counter machine
that I have let's just take a short
commercial break while I do that
the Arg for the Cloverfield paradox
actually began in real life in summer
2017 at San Diego comic-con where fans
could actually purchase a slusho from
the mobile slusho truck at the event
each slushy flavor had its own robot
mascot which is probably due to the fact
that the studio behind the film's is bad
robot there's actually a 7th robot who
was a combination of each flavor the 7th
robot appeared on the slush show
snapchat filter if you align the 7th
robot in the blank space of the truck
and showed the snapchat to the slusho
employee you were asked to fill out a
form to win a prize for solving the
puzzle and that would be just the
beginning though On January 18th which
happens to be the 10-year anniversary of
the original Cloverfield the tag hirato
website is updated but upon trying to
access it you'll receive an error
message
however examining the image behind the
error message leads to a text post that
reads as follows
Tokyo January 18 2018 Tiger ATO has
begun development of revolutionary new
energy technology in what CEO Gallo
Yoshida called a technological great
leap forward for our planet this
renewable energy it will take at least
four years to complete along with
another six years international
regulatory bodies to bring this powerful
revolutionary energy source by April 18
2028 I think we can make the conclusion
that the energy technology referenced is
Shepherd from the Cloverfield paradox I
believe that the Arg like the other two
energies before it take place in real
time here in 2018 the movie which
doesn't occur until the shepherd exists
takes place in 2028 the thing I'm not
sure about yet is whether it takes place
in dimension a the Cloverfield universe
dimension being the 10 Cloverfield Lane
universe or dimensions C and D to
theoretical entirely new universes I'll
give my arguments for each possibility
as we progress but I think whatever
dimension the movie takes place in is
not our dimension the one that you're
watching this video in right now I'd say
internet browsers in that universe works
slightly different so if we access the
webpage in Google Chrome Firefox or
other popular web browsers from our
universe the page glitches out I
wouldn't rule out the possibility that
someone
our dimension can build a browser that
will read the page properly maybe we
just haven't discovered it yet in the
Arg moving forward not much happens on
the website until January 27th when it
becomes possible to spot a graphic about
something called the Cloverfield energy
initiative this time there's a faded
handwriting on top of the graphic but
manipulating the image allows us to see
the true message it says someone needs
to stop this from happening this is
nothing but a cover for a reckless
experiment that will reset the world's
grid stop this to save the world
tidal wave if you'll remember tidal wave
is the same group that opposed tagger
Otto's deep-sea drilling project back in
the era of the original Cloverfield Arg
also on January 27th the first winners
of the slusho truck puzzle challenge I
mentioned earlier receive their prizes
in the mail the prize package included a
slusho bobble head a certificate of
congratulations with trademarks
registered by bold Futura the satellite
company Howard Stambler worked for and a
pamphlet version of the Cloverfield
energy initiative graphic spotted on the
background of the tagger Auto websites
the most recent update to the tiger ATO
website introduces a hebrew news article
from 2007 that talks about road closures
near the Dead Sea possibly because of
sinkholes as a reminder that would be a
little over a year before the New York
City attack that is if it even happens
on this timeline let's go back to the
release date of tiger Otto's new energy
source April 18 2028 if you go to 418
2028 calm a distorted video plays this
page also continued to update over the
course of January and we get little bits
of information piece by piece from what
appears to be a guy wearing glasses some
of the lines that we can make out
include the following a male voice says
this is what I'm trying to warn you
about the dangers of what tag Watsa was
trying to do in an update a female voice
can be heard saying welcome to the show
Cloverfield Station joining us today
controversy mark Stambler author of the
book so this mark Stambler has the same
last name as howard Stambler
guy who built the bunker in 10
Cloverfield Lane the last update from
the O 418 2028 website looks like this
[Music]
[Music]
in case II couldn't make it out
mark Stambler says the experiment could
unleash chaos the likes of which we have
never seen you have no idea how much I
would love to be wrong about this it
would be no fun for me to be right if
you want to know more read my book there
was also a mark Stambler twitter
accounts at one point some users who
attempted to DM the account received a
message containing more cryptic videos
unfortunately they're very hard to
decipher because he actually sent them
as vertical videos of the computer
screen as opposed to just sending the
actual video file the account is no
longer up and the only tweets were about
some hoax at the University he works at
and how he had to notify NYPD about
someone watching him this information
doesn't actually tie directly into the
movie but I just thought I would mention
it because it tells us more about the
character and it makes me think that
someone from tag Watsu has a reason to
keep an eye on this mark Stambler
character okay so as of right now that's
as much as we know from the Arg but
before I tell you the things he missed
from the movie there's one more thing
I'd like to point out in the trailer it
says ten years ago something arrived now
find out why then it immediately cuts to
a shot of the Shepard I would say that
could support the idea that the
Cloverfield paradox takes place in
dimension a but the event caused by the
firing of the Shepard could take place
across multiple dimensions which I will
explain later in this video early in the
movie Ava and Michael are in a huge line
at the gas station and it's the
fictional Kelvin gas station which is
also where Michelle stops to get gas in
10 Cloverfield Lane if you pause on that
shot you can also get an idea of how bad
the energy crisis discussed in the movie
really
the sign says gas available today as if
that is a rarity and it cost $30 a
gallon
there's also another appearance towards
the end of the movie which may suggest
that Kelvin was in on the Cloverfield
energy initiative when Ava gets back in
the car she asked her husband if he's
movie yet and he jokes however this
could also be a foreshadowing of the
journey taken by those aboard the
Cloverfield Station later in this film
if you're looking at a timeline and they
continue to move forward in time but
they also go sideways into a different
dimension and while we're on this topic
I think now is a good time to bring up
the logo and poster of this movie and
before you start to say that it's just a
poster and it doesn't matter remember
that we have seen clues on the
Cloverfield posters before but this time
I specifically want to look at the logo
if we look at the 10 Cloverfield Lane
poster it has one timeline leading from
the Cloverfield text to the place where
the movie takes place but this
Cloverfield paradox poster looks all too
familiar for someone who spent time
studying split timelines the logo is
definitely supposed to represent the
timelines of the two dimensions occupied
by the Cloverfield station one of them
comes off the letter L which could mean
that the dimension that they travel to
is dimension be from 10 Cloverfield Lane
before they get their gasoline there's a
blackout which Ava says is the fourth or
fifth one of the day in both prequels
the calamity started with the blackout
or multiple blackouts
what the hell was that during the
opening title sequence onboard the
station we see the team picture of the
international crew after they cross over
to the other dimension a different photo
is seen they also have this tank of
worms which is supposed to be there to
consume bacteria but they disappear
after crossing over worms are later
found inside a bull cough but these
worms look much smaller compared to the
ones in the tank if the dimension that
they travel to really is dimension B
then it could be possible that the
disappearance of the worms aboard the
spacecraft is related to the appearance
of vicious worm like aliens in 10
Cloverfield Lane let me know what you
think in the comments
ava has a video chat with her husband
where he tries to bring up the idea that
maybe they should try to go back and
have kids again after the accidental
death of their first two kids in a fire
however the ripple created by the firing
of the shepherd seems to occur at
different places on the timeline in
different dimensions so maybe the idea
of going back in time isn't that
far-fetched it also sets up the later
plot point where Ava finds herself with
an opportunity to save her children in
the other dimension while they're
preparing to fire up the shepherd again
Acosta tunes into an earth akin TV
broadcast and we finally get to see the
full video that had been teased on the
AU for 18 20:28 website with mark
Stambler being interviewed live the
title of his book is the Cloverfield
paradox and his twitter handle is at
paradoxes real which is a real account
created in January the same time the
online portion of the Arg started but it
hasn't posted anything yet here's what
Mark has to say about it
he ever built every time they tested
they was ripping open the membrane of
space-time smashing - given multiple
dimensions shattering reality and not
just on that station everywhere this
experiment could chaos the likes of
which we have never seen so while this
guy may appear to be crazy for the time
being he turns out to be 100% right so
where does he get this information let's
also not forget that marks brother
Howard Stambler knew exactly when the
calamity was going to hit in 10
Cloverfield Lane and what it was going
to entail in the Arg he tries to get his
daughter to come down to his bunker well
in advance
he knows he's low on time before the
disaster happens so he knocks Michelle
off the road Emmet explains that he was
nearby right when the huge flash hit and
he raced straight to the bunker where
Howard was already closing the door
Howard knew exactly how to prepare for
what was coming and he did so the
question is how did these brothers
effectively predict the future when
nobody else could that could be a
question answered in another movie let's
continue Mark's speech this could be the
key to understanding how everything
we've seen so far is linked let's assume
for a moment that we're dealing with for
entirely different dimensions maybe at
the time that the Shepherd overloads in
dimension C dimension a is still only in
2008 and so the Cloverfield incident
occurs maybe at the same time in
dimension B it's still 2016 so the 10
Cloverfield Lane attack hits and maybe
dimension D is parallel and the event
destroys their Cloverfield station there
is more evidence outside of just taking
mark Stan blurs word for it to suggest
that this is one event taking place in
multiple timelines at different times
let's revisit Emmett's description of
the event that triggered the cataclysm
in 10 Cloverfield Lane the attack I saw
myself what do you mean it's on my way
home from work
and it looked like a flash bright red
like an explosion from way far off
I wasn't like fireworks no it was more
like something you read about in the
Bible
so what you saw what a flash of light
lightning a fire that flared up I'm not
explaining it right this wasn't like
anything I've ever seen
seems awfully familiar and after seeing
the Cloverfield paradox another
connection 10 Cloverfield Lane can be
found in Michael's social media feed
after the first explosion first of all I
do hope we're running on a 7g network in
the next 10 years but the posts are all
talking about a huge noise several
missing city blocks and part of the city
in rubble but one of the posts is a
question asking if anyone's been outside
and wondering if the air is safe to
breathe
a quick note when Michael saves the
little girl he puts on a cartoon for her
called bleep bloop which appears to be
about the mascot of the production
company bad robot but could also have
something to do with the robot flavors
seen on the side of the slusho truck
it's more likely to be a reference to
bad robot since the credits say the
animation was created by JJ Abrams and
Ben Schwartz and bad robot is JJ Abrams
company here's another interesting bit
during the Shepard overload the whole
station starts shaking and we see a shot
of the slusho bobblehead
the same one that the comic-con fans in
2017 were given for solving the slusho
puzzle this is the first of many
parallels to the first Cloverfield movie
another theory that I have is that the
dimension that the Cloverfield paradox
takes place in is the same as dimension
a except for the fact that the
Cloverfield incident hasn't happened yet
at this time instead of happening in New
York City it's happening in space an
early reference to slusho just before
the disaster strikes is one of many
parallels we'll see when they first find
in rescue mina
she has a beam watch in her shoulder in
the same spot that Beth is impaled by a
beam when they rescue her in the
original Cloverfield speaking of Beth
she reaches out to Rob via her cell
phone to let him know that she's trapped
in her apartment michael reads on his
cell phone about one of his friends
being trapped in an apartment after the
calamity hits the person is trapped in
402 p a street that may or may not be
related to helicopter number 402 which
Lily gets taken away in during the first
movie in the shot we can see a monster
in the background wrecking a city with
huge skyscrapers it's assumed that this
is somewhere in the UK but we never find
out what city it is and finally in order
to save the space station they have to
prevent it from tilting off axis by 25
degrees Beth's apartment is also tilting
off axis by just under
25 degrees they end up going to the
building next to it and the three main
characters have to traverse the ruins of
the roof to get to the door that they
need to get to the scene where the
astronauts had it cross over to get to
the other part of the space station is
almost identical then there's the
villain of the movie in this movie Mina
is portrayed as the villain even though
she's just trying to help her own planet
we don't know a whole lot about clover
but it appears that the destruction
caused by it is just due to its
self-defense instincts as well when we
first discover Mina they hear the sounds
of clovers roar on the other side of the
wall and when Mina is on the attack at
the end of the movie we also hear the
distant sound of that roar
and of course Cloverfield ends with a
mysterious object which is assumed to be
a satellite or Space Shuttle crashing
into the Atlantic Ocean which is exactly
where the pod from the Cloverfield
paradox lands and while this does answer
some questions about what caused the
calamity in each movie it also raises
plenty of questions
what role did tiger also have in the
opening of this spacetime tear and how
do all of these films fit together I'm
going to talk about the three most
plausible scenarios scenario number one
the Cloverfield paradox takes place in
its own universe dimension C the firing
of the shepard causes space-time tears
in all four dimensions and monsters
creatures from the sea and demons travel
to earth through these tears the event
pushes the Cloverfield station into
dimension D and when they overload the
Shepard again they push themselves back
into dimension C this would explain why
there's never any mention of a previous
calamity in either sequel and why clover
appears to be much much bigger than the
monster in Cloverfield this is the
easiest and least creative scenario and
it wastes the opportunity to tie in the
object landing at the end of Cloverfield
to the shuttle landing in paradox
scenario number two the Cloverfield
paradox takes place in dimension a 20
years after the New York Cloverfield
incident after the events of Cloverfield
the monster is captured or goes back
into hiding however an accident caused
by yoshida medical research causes their
cellular growth accelerant used for
healing injured humans to blow clover up
to a much bigger more destructive size
when they fire the Shepard this process
is sped up and it creates a disaster on
earth while the space station is pushed
into dimension B the paradox causes a
huge flash which gets the attention of
the aliens possibly the Martians
to get here their weapons a lake through
skis look like like sticks and stones
whose set to wipe out human life on
earth they fire the Shepherd again and
come back to dimension egg at the end to
find it in ruins scenario number three
the Cloverfield paradox takes place in
dimension C the Shepherd tears
space-time so that disasters also happen
in 2008 and 2016 in dimension a and B
respectively
when the Shepherd is fired they travel
to dimension B or D but when it's fired
again to get back home
they actually unknowingly go to
dimension a which is similar to their
dimension but clover has been growing
and on the loose for over 20 years but
that of course still doesn't solve the
question of what landed in the water at
the end of Cloverfield and last scenario
number 4 they went back in time to 2008
dimension a but that doesn't explain why
clover is awake and giant at the time of
their landing while in Cloverfield there
was no issue until a month after the
object landed there are so many
possibilities here so if you have your
own theories leave them in the comments
I'd love to piece this one together but
chances are we won't get answers until a
future movie and there's also a
possibility that the Arg for this movie
isn't over yet so if you'd like to see
me cover any updates we might see let me
hear in the comments on that one as well
if you were confused at any point in
this video go ahead and leave a like my
name is Susie and I love talking about
psychological horror but honestly my
brain is pretty wrecked on this one but
regardless I'll be back with new Horrors
every week so make sure you subscribe to
see ZZZ world and bring the death Bell
so you can see those and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive